nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
c'est un phénomène particulièrement
fréquent au Japon chaque année des
milliers de Japonais disparaissent
volontairement il s'évapore
littéralement il planifie leur
disparition et un jour subitement coupe
tout lien avec leurs proches et partent
reconstruire leur vie ailleurs que
font-ils ou vont-ils pourquoi
partent-ils Constantin Simon vous avez
enquêté sur ces disparus le phénomène
est si répandu au Japon que la langue
japonaise dispose dispose même d'un
terme spécial pour qualifier ces départs
mystérieux phénomène qui s'est accentué
avec la crise économique des années 90
oui tout à fait au Japon on parle de
johatsu donc de d'évaporation intermacé
poétique finalement pour une réalité
triste évidemment c'est un phénomène qui
existe en fait depuis des siècles au
Japon mais qui sait accentué dans les
années 90 alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé à cette époque là tout simplement
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale en 40
45 ans le Japon c'est recons une vitesse
incroyable et dans les années 80 il y a
énormément d'argent qui circulent dans
le pays les gens investissent beaucoup
et puis il y a cette crise économique
qui commence à ravager le pays dans les
années 90 et donc des gens se retrouvent
subitement ruinés avec des recouvreurs
de dettes qu'il est pour chassent avec
parfois même des yakuzas qui les
menacent et ils se sentent coincés à une
voix comme issue que le suicide ou la
disparition et c'est à cette époque
comme vous allez le voir dans le
reportage et bien il y a même des
manuels pour aider les gens à
disparaître qui sont publiés alors nous
partons donc sur les traces de ces
fantômes du Japon enquêtes sur les
évaporations signées Constantin Simon
Yuko Sano Arouna popuri et Louis Belin
[Musique]
et
Gomez voilà
[Musique]
il y a quatre ans Makiko 21 ans s'est
enfui de sa maison
pour plutôt que cette lettre
j'aurais aimé qu'elle vienne me parler
je n'arrive toujours pas à y croire
[Musique]
malgré le désir de retrouver ma Kiko ses
parents ne souhaitent pas révéler leur
identité
tout est resté comme c'était
le temps s'est arrêté dans cette chambre
comme pour bien montrer qu'elle s'en
allait pour toujours leur fille a laissé
ses affaires son sac son portefeuille
son téléphone et même sur le rebord de
sa fenêtre
sa clé
je me dis que peut-être elle ne
reviendra jamais
que c'est vraiment la fin
il faut que je l'accepte
si elle ne veut pas me revoir pourquoi
la forcer
Makiko avait des difficultés
psychologiques elle sortait d'une
rupture sentimentale son corps n'a pas
été retrouvé ce qui exclut l'hypothèse
d'un suicide
pour la police c'est bien une fuite
avec ma femme après la disparition on
venait s'asseoir sur ce banc une
demi-heure ou une heure on observez les
piétons ainsi que les gens à l'intérieur
des voitures Inna et quand on espérait
la percevoir
[Musique]
particularité japonaise si le disparu
est majeur et semble être parti
volontairement s'il n'y a pas de risque
de suicide de crimes ou d'accident la
police n'en quittera pas
à l'inverse en France les affaires
laissées par maki Co et sa fragilité
psychologique aurait permis de
déclencher une enquête
[Musique]
le Japon a inventé un droit à
disparaître
même si nous avons déclaré la
disparition la police n'a rien fait
c'est ça la réalité
souvent on se rendait au commissariat
même tard la nuit ça nous arrivait 7 ou
8 fois par mois aucun ma femme n'allait
pas bien elle était psychologiquement
instable
un jour la police nous a dit nous
n'avons pas que l'affaire de votre fille
a traité savez-vous combien de gens
disparaissent au Japon par an 90 000
on souhaite qu'elle soit en vie mais on
se dit aussi qu'elle est peut-être morte
c'est sans fin on tourne en rond et on
va sûrement penser à cela toute notre
vie ils sont
qu'il a pas rêvé un jour de tout quitter
de tout recommencer à zéro
au Japon c'est possible il y a même un
mot pour cela les johatsu les
évaporations
des milliers de personnes choisissent
chaque année d'organiser leur propre
disparition pour refaire leur vieilleur
échec professionnel ou scolaire
endettement sénilité Marie violent
dispute familiale les raisons des
départs sont multiples et parfois
obscures
[Musique]
si la police ne fait rien il reste les
détectives
patience persévérance ce sont les
maîtres mots de cette enquêteur privé
dont le centre ville de Tokyo il
recherche un homme de 27 ans évaporé il
y a une semaine
excusez-moi de vous déranger c'est pour
un renseignement je cherche quelqu'un
n'auriez-vous pas vu ces derniers jours
une personne qui ressemble à cette photo
regretté par la famille du disparu se
détective se concentre aujourd'hui sur
les hôtels bon marché de la capitale
cet homme a fait beaucoup de
déplacements par-ci par là grâce à son
portable on a pu retracer l'historique
de ses réservations d'hôtel
à la limite de la légalité certains
détectives ont des réseaux
d'informateurs dans les compagnies de
téléphone mais ils doivent aussi tenter
au petit bonheur la chance
parfois ça va vite et on trouve
rapidement parfois on trouve après deux
ou trois hôtels
ce jour-là l'enquêteur va en visiter une
cinquantaine et constituée un dossier
avec photo et possible témoignage
vous êtes de la police non
alors c'est un peu compliqué pour nous
de vous parler
je vois mais juste tout vous-même vous
l'auriez pas vu s'il vous plaît ces
derniers temps comme on est tous masqués
dans ce pays où la vie privée est
sacro-sainte recrutée un détective coûte
cher 500 euros par jour pour des
résultats un certain
[Musique]
alors pour répondre aux désespoir des
familles cet ancien policier a créé il y
a 20 ans une association pour aider
gratuitement à la recherche des disparus
ce matin il retrouve ce père de famille
qui pendant trois ans n'avait plus de
nouvelles de son fils en étudiant les
relevés de compte du disparus le père
obtient un jour un indice quelqu'un sans
doute son fils retire de l'argent dans
cette bande
au Japon il y a une loi qui protège les
données personnelles et quand je me suis
rendu à la banque et que je leur ai
demandé s'il pouvait m'aider à me
montrant la vidéo de surveillance du
distributeur ils ont refusé en disant
que c'était justement des données
personnelles privées
j'ai eu le même problème avec la
compagnie de son téléphone portable je
leur ai demandé s'il ne pouvait pas
partager avec moi les coordonnées GPS du
téléphone
mais ils ont refusé pour la même raison
depuis les abus militaristes de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale la Constitution
nippone est très protectrice des
libertés individuelles il est quasiment
impossible d'obtenir des informations
sur des individus sans leur consentement
quand je voyais que le compte en banque
était vide je mettais un peu d'argent
dessus et cet argent était tout de suite
retiré dont j'en mettais encore
si mon fils retirait de l'argent cela
voulait dire qu'il était encore en vie
j'étais tellement rassuré à chaque fois
que je voyais ces retraits c'était comme
un lien entre mon fils et moi
[Musique]
il y a trois mois son fils a fini par
rentrer une exception
les disparus sont aujourd'hui si
nombreux que des sociétés aident les
gens à disparaître on les appelle les
déménageurs de nuit pour quelques
milliers d'euros ils emportent vos
meubles discrètement peuvent même vous
loger provisoirement dans un lieu secret
et tout est parfaitement légal
journaliste d'investigation américain
installés à Tokyo depuis 30 ans Jake
Adelstein enquête sur ce phénomène qui a
aussi ses manuels la disparition pour
les nuls
V6 voici la Bible pour disparaître elle
vous dira tout ce qu'il faut faire non
seulement pour disparaître mais pour que
personne ne vous retrouve cela inclut la
lettre qu'il faut écrire et laisser
derrière soi disons aux gens que tout va
bien
que je ne suis pas blessé en danger que
je suis juste fatigué de cette vie et
que j'ai besoin de partir mais que je
contrevenir un jour c'est important
parce que si vous dites ça la police ne
va pas entamer une enquête pour vous
retrouver ces disparitions seraient un
échappatoire à la pression d'une société
nippone qui ne tolère pas l'échec et a
toujours placé l'harmonie du groupe
au-dessus du bonheur des individus
au Japon les gens vivent mal avec la
honte ici les gens ne pardonnent pas
plutôt que de vivre avec la honte ou des
dettes certaines personnes préféreront
choisir de tout quitter de disparaître
et de recommencer une vie
certains se débrouillent plutôt bien ou
bien alors ils choisissent de quitter ce
monde et de mettre fin à leurs jours
évidemment je défends qu'il est mieux de
s'enfuir que de se suicider tes deux de
ses livres sont vraiment sur ce thème ne
vous tuez pas disparaissez recommencez
votre vie le Japon reste le pays du G7
avec le taux de suicide le plus élevé
pendant des mois nous avons essayé en
vain de contacter des disparus
parcourant le Japon à la recherche de
ses fantômes
et c'est finalement dans les faubourgs
de Saka que cet étrange enquête va nous
mener
le quartier de camagasaki est le symbole
de la récession économique qui a frappé
ce pays riche dans les années 90
sans emploi sans argent beaucoup de
Japonais ne voyaient plus comme solution
que la fuite et le phénomène des
disparitions connu au Japon depuis le
Moyen-âge a pris alors une ampleur
inédite
depuis 30 ans les âmes perdues du Japon
échouent ici
un des rares endroits où ils se sentent
tolérés
cette église aide les plus démunis
[Musique]
dans le passé ils sont déçus
ils n'ont plus d'espoir ils ont perdu le
sens de la vie
non ni vision
ni rêve
[Musique]
lui vit entre des cartons depuis 27 ans
originaire du nord du Japon ce
sexagénaire est arrivé ici après avoir
perdu son travail couvert de dettes de
jeu
pour être honnête avec vous j'ai perdu
ma vie à cause des paris des choses
variées comme les courses de chevaux
mon frère ne pouvait pas continuer à
s'occuper de moi éternellement
c'était mal vu dans son entourage sa
belle-famille donc j'ai réfléchi et j'ai
décidé de partir vivre tout seul
vous êtes parti sans rien dire
je me suis dit vider votre vie moi je
vis la mienne et j'ai rompu tout contact
aujourd'hui j'ai dans les 60 ans à cet
âge j'aurais pu avoir déjà des petits
enfants mais si je meurs comme je n'ai
plus aucun lien avec mes frères et mes
sœurs et bien je m'étonnerai seul c'est
ma vie que voulez-vous c'est tout
les naufragés de camagasaki ne sont pas
tous des évaporés et tous les évaporés
ne finissent pas à la rue
pendant trois ans la pandémie a ralenti
les disparitions à cause des difficultés
à voyager et face à la peur du virus ils
étaient moins nombreux à oser partir
mais les difficultés économiques
actuelles risquent de pousser davantage
de malheureux à fuir
et le quartier de camagasaki n'a pas
fini de voir aérer des fantômes
[Musique]
et on retrouve Constantin Simon qui est
réalisé ce reportage Constantin enquêté
n'a pas été facile tant le sujet est
sensible oui exactement c'est un sujet
compliqué notamment en télévision
évidemment faire parler des morts et
c'est d'entrer en contact avec des gens
qui ont coupé tout contact avec la
société ou en tout cas avec leur famille
ça n'était pas aisé pas aisé non plus
évidemment d'entrer en contact avec les
familles des disparus et d'accepter de
de qu'il témoignent en fait dans les
reportages parce que en fait ils sont
vraiment comme on l'a vu avec cette
première famille dans le reportage
tiraillé entre d'un côté le désir de
communiquer de faire ce reportage pour
que peut-être le disparu et bien tout
simplement le voit que cela permette un
témoin de se révéler de donner des
indices et de l'autre côté évidemment la
terrible honte qu'ils éprouvent et puis
le désespoir ce sont des des gens qui
sont dans une détresse psychologique
énorme finalement nous avons réussi à
trouver un disparu il a fallu pour cela
aller à Osaka et arpenter déambuler ro
la nuit dans le quartier malfamé de
camagasaki un c'est un quartier très
particulier où on voit des gens qui
dorment dans la rue c'est une image très
rare au Japon ou il y a peu de SDF ou en
tout cas les pauvres se cachent et ne
m'en dit pas et bien j'ai vraiment une
impression si vous voulez que toute la
misère du Japon c'était concentré dans
ce quartier Constantin est-ce qu'il y a
vraiment plus de gens qui disparaissent
au Japon que dans d'autres pays alors
c'est difficile à évaluer il y a un
débat sur les chiffres évidemment qu'il
y a des disparitions dans d'autres pays
si on en reste même aux chiffres
officiels il y a entre 80 et 90 000
disparitions par an et la très grande
majorité ces disparitions sont des gens
qui sont en fait retrouvés et ça c'est
un chiffre à peu près comparable à ceux
des autres pays mais c'est quand on
demande l'avis des associations des gens
des spécialistes c'est là qu'on découvre
qu'en effet beaucoup de ces disparitions
au Japon ne seraient pas déclarés
pourquoi et bien parce que les gens et
bien on monte comme on l'a vu et ou
alors tout simplement pense que ça ne
sert à rien de contact c'était la police
puisque de toute façon la police ne fera
rien ça c'est vraiment la particularité
japonaise c'est que depuis les abus
militaristes de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale ou l'état demandé aux gens de
faire beaucoup de choses les
réquisitionner pour l'effort de guerre
et bien il y a des lois pour protéger
les libertés individuelles et
aujourd'hui si quelqu'un ne veut pas
donner d'information sur lui-même et
bien ça sera très difficile même pour la
police ou les détectives privées de
retrouver cette personne l'autre
particularité les culturelles il y a une
un rapport à la vie privée presque
sacro-saint au Japon on ne parle pas on
ne pose pas trop de questions et puis
enfin la si la plupart des disparitions
et bien son volontaires il y a aussi des
disparitions de gens qui en fait sont
atteints de sénilité dans cette
population qui est très âgée évidemment
Constantin Simon duplexe merci beaucoup
Constantin c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci à vous de l'avoir suivie et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]